it's absolutely impossible to start a
review of dread without showing this so
I'm back from tiff guys I had a great
time the Toronto International Film
Festival I saw just about every film I
wanted to see the second film I saw
after looper was Dredd 3d it was at
Midnight Madness and for those who don't
know they show a film at midnight every
day of the week and it's like a fantasy
sci-fi horror action type film and the
crowd for it is just it's great there
the film fan like the super film nerds
and they just want to see a fun movie
the dreads kind of like a remake of the
Judge Dredd film with Sylvester Stallone
but it's really more of an adaptation of
the comic that stays more true to the
comic now buddy of mine said this is the
type of movie they actually should
remake not a great movie like the
original Total Recall but a movie that
was made and it wasn't very good
yeah the original Judge Dredd has it's
cult followers and everything but let's
face it the movie sucked this movie
stars Karl Urban as Judge Dredd it's
this futuristic world where the police
officers are judges who wear like this
full suit body armor helmets everything
and they have the ability to be judge
jury and executioner to whoever they
choose and this trailer looks so bad I
mean it was horrible I was loathing
seeing this movie it just looked so
terrible this movie was awesome what is
going on people are loving this movie
not just people but critics I mean
they're digging this movie and for good
reason this movie was awesome this
movie's essentially non-stop action I
mean pretty much almost entirely
non-stop action Judge Dredd and his new
partner who is a rookie played by Olivia
therby get locked down in this apartment
building that's completely owned by this
drug lord and everything kind of like
the raid I guess yeah definitely hmm
it's just so entertaining this movie is
just such a perfect b-movie it's just so
much fun the action in the choreography
is really well done the movie looks
magnificent it's shot extremely well
there's this new drug that people are
passing around in this movie where you
take it's like an inhaler and it slows
down time they get a lot of really cool
effects with that they show like
first-person view of people taking the
drug and then like the slow-mo
like we're
yeah the movie is actually kind of
beautiful looking I mean I'm laughing
just the fact that I said Dredd 3d is
beautiful looking if you're looking for
a movie with a lot of substance yeah
you're not looking at the right movie
it's actually well acted Judge Dredd as
a hero in this movie is really
entertaining and Karl Urban just he just
he's very good for only having his mouth
I mean he's actually really good in this
movie I liked Olivia thir B's character
as well she played a psychic they had
great chemistry as one another the main
villain in this film is played by the
woman from Game of Thrones
she was disgusting and I really bought
that she was disgusting like a depraved
person another thing I liked about this
movie was they have judge jury and
executioner privileges and they'll do
bad with that like they showed how Judge
Dredd was trying to do good things but
there were other judges who weren't and
I like how they showed that comparison
because really when you give a police
officer of some kind just that much
authority more than likely there gonna
be some that are not so great of people
and some that are more better this one
was actually clever and really smart and
it had some things to say about
Authority and everything to it just it
was a fun b-movie it wasn't stupid it
was not as bad as a trailer mayor look
that's probably the worst trailer I've
ever seen come to think of it because of
how bad it made it look but this movie
is awesome I'm gonna give Dredd a B+
simply because it's nothing amazingly
special it's just a really fun time so
that was a second movie I saw at TIFF
pretty soon I'm going to have more
reviews for you for the place beyond the
pines Cloud Atlas Seven Psychopaths the
impossible and much much more thanks for
watching guys and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck my eyes
Oh